the dover brothers listen up
kids if you like slime and you like
prank videos
i got great news for you there's an
abundance
slime prank on lucas and marcus slime
prank on pizzagun
slime break on girlfriend slay prank or
brother star
slime back on girlfriend again in hot
tub
hmm slime prank on little sister
slime prank on cop gone wrong the dover
brothers is my favorite
slime prank channel they really know how
to make the slime prank
to the top but what a lot of people
don't appreciate the dover brothers for
is their incredible craft
and art of music videos
i was flipping through my marble floor
dropping this
track you already wanting more god gives
me
everything we playing for the people who
keep hating
teach us 60 million views huh
60 million six miller 60 minutes 60
minutes 60 minutes
60 million i want
60 million views if you ain't scared hit
it like you don't
care hit it if you know you live hey
guys peeps from the future here just
wanna let you guys know really quick
that right now today
you can get an elgato stream deck for 99
instead of 149.
wow what a great deal i love mine i
think it's such a cool device you can
basically map
any app or any function like obs which i
used to record
to this thing if your streamer it's a
given to have one of these
it has so much customizability that you
can literally put anything on this if
you want to open an app
if you want to use a sound board it's
really really cool definitely recommend
it and since it on a special offer
link is in the description okay continue
with the video now if you guys are nine
years old i
you can tell the dober brothers audience
are
slightly younger here if you go in the
comments it says you said
a cuss word i'm seven years old this is
so irresponsible i would never cuss in
my videos
and my audience is nine years old thank
you but what i find fascinating
about the dobre brothers videos is
their prank their attention to detail on
the prank because a lot of people
fake their pranks but but not the dobry
brothers
they're beyond that they know how to
pull off a great prank
without staging it with genuine
reactions
genuine emotions and charges and you
really really feel it this one is called
mom wakes up
in ocean prank no we gotta go again
ready three two one
we're twins and we do the box all right
why are we doing this right now to our
mom this is the best prank ever
ever they're not lying it's this is my
favorite prank of all time
they come up with this strange idea that
they're gonna take the hotels
mattress while the mom is sleeping she's
clearly sleeping
maybe they drugged her i'm sure i'm
gonna decide they're gonna pull
this mattress oh well he looks like
she's gonna
oh that was close guys they decided to
take this mattress
out until the ocean how you may ask
how would they possibly fit through that
narrow
corridor a doorway don't worry because
they don't show it
just tell them
the video's like five minutes of them
painfully trying to get this mattress
out of this they're stealing a mattress
from a hotel
the dad is really trying he really wants
to pull this off
[Music]
papa wants some views how are they gonna
fit the mattress in the elevator
[Music]
i can't believe she's still sleeping
this is incredible
they drag her all the way from the hotel
to the sea front
oh oh my god my god
why are we still here guys right away
what should we do
every night big wave
[Music]
won't stop
how did she get there i have no idea
don't you just hate when you fall asleep
in a hotel bedroom
and your sons carry you through the
hallway with your mattress
you know what i have to be honest i knew
it was a prank
really what really
she knew
ah then who's getting pranked
really you knew it was a prank the
double prankster a classic
they pulled this move a lot of times
we're really sorry like
we meant nothing of it did you laugh uh
what is this going wrong
joke's on you dobro you know natalie
malarkey wait what
the double prank what happened just now
what just happened right now i've seen
better acting on adult websites jesus
christ
but the thing that's so confusing about
it is that
they're always pranking everyone is
always in on it
but no one seems to be understand when
it's real and when it's fake
you have all of a sudden this guy just
crying
and everyone's like what is this
what's wrong with him funny
[Music]
bro so apparently he lost his dog and to
find him
yeah i actually just like fixed his
flashlight
no i love him he's like god i don't know
he says it like the dog is
he's gone forever romeo man i loved him
he was a
he was the father to me it was like the
son i never had
too bad he's dead now all right um
i don't know maybe they're still in on
it i don't know i
i'm so confused by this video they go
around looking everywhere
i don't know is that right they even get
us some security guy involved
yeah i'll definitely keep the lights on
and i'll start canvassing for them for
you guys
and then they just wake up the day after
so i'm going to warn you guys about this
next clip it's pretty offensive
here we go i really feel sorry for cyrus
like
he was texting us all night but we just
couldn't find him
and the security guard was out till 5 00
am couldn't find him
the kindergarten was out until 5am
looking for their dog
now we're just gonna uh we're just gonna
look inside
the whole house yo he's in there
oh he's in the pool house oh it's not oh
i told you i need someone left him in
there when we made the burgers man i
knew it
romeo what are you doing in there
romeo all right they found
them did they actually like hide his dog
just to
i don't get it i'm so confused i'm so
confused
and it's the same with like this this
video the best
proposal in the world you're like oh
that's clearly
going to be some stupid prank right what
are you doing
i love you come here give me kiss
you're the most amazing girl in the
world you're my dream girl
and i want to always protect you i want
to always protect you
keep you comforted and i wanna give you
the world
okay i wanna make you happy every day
so they have the drone fly down
he grabs the ring with the drone best
proposal
in the world what's actually real like
what is real and what is fake i don't
understand
i need answers to break brother best
proposal
in the world we had a drone
fly down with a ring
i love you what i carry you
i wanna always protect you i wanna
always protect you keep you comforted
and i wanna give you the world
i just love how self-aware they are
that's uh
i hope he doesn't get mad though this is
one club
i think hopefully we're okay i mean you
know i'm not gonna lie though guys
vlogging and driving is pretty hard so
uh make sure you don't vlog and drive
kids
or text and drive none of that stuff but
uh tune in
because we are gonna keep the vlog going
and
don't vlog and drive guys
proceeds to vlog and drive oh my god
cyrus is literally calling me right now
he's blowing up your phone too wait hold
on i have to answer why can't she hold
the camera okay
jesus christ
you may have seen this video already
it's uh
it's another dober brother classic
they have this they have these wide
arrangements of tools
and they have to guess which one is real
and which one is fake wouldn't the real
ones be
cold because it's metal
oh you mean like how you can just lift
it up and tell some of them
are chocolate that's right chocolate
that's not chocolate
chocolate the one that's super heavy
that one is real what
the one that's cold it's this might
actually
be a little bit more about that i mean
they're all pretty much the same weight
here too
that's right everybody chocolate weighs
the same as metal
everyone knows that they're all pretty
much the same way pretty much
here we have the video where they're
clearly pouring slime on
the girlfriend i love seeing slime on
girlfriends
i must say it's the strongest bet this
song goes out to anyone
who thinks they don't matter but that's
me
know that you do oh thank you
let's go let's go think you ain't good
enough stop that
i think you ain't beautiful stop that
think you ain't worth it stop that
i think you ain't love for stop that
goodbye to the people who hate it on
me you know what i admire by the dover
brothers is that they don't get a
ghostwriter like
ricegum and all those other ones they
write their own material
i myself you as you i'm myself you is
you
what they're really saying here is that
consciousness
is something that we all have to be
conscious of not just is me
but also is you they realize they're
missing
you beautiful you strong they won't be
there for long
hey you know what you are you're
beautiful
you're strong
and if you're at this point thinking
about at least you know they make
something that
has a deeper meaning it's an
anti-bullying video maybe it's not that
good but at least they tried you know at
least they're not
trying to be like team 10 oh no no no
no no no no hey we back there's more
dobre brothers it's about to get lit
remix
[Music]
wow they got six nine
started from the grocery store now i own
hawaii
them heads spinning when i pass i do my
dance all
on the floor dropping this track you
already coming back for more
i don't mean to make fun of them like if
they actually have issues like maybe
they actually have autism or something i
don't
mean to pick on people you know i'm not
trying to leafy people here but
what's wrong with them
[Music]
see i watched this video before uh i
knew who
takashi was six nine and i actually
thought it was him
like they do a good job at covering up
his face
making sure that you can't see i wonder
what it
he thinks about this this video has 31
million views
there you go there you have it everybody
the dobry brothers now you are
filled in it amazes me what an
army of kids there is on youtube that
will just give an abundance of views to
literally anything that looks shiny and
interesting
these people really make it look easy
and at least you can admire that i don't
have anything personally against them
i think it's just hilarious how bad
their videos are and they completely
gone under my radar
it seems like these people just crawl
out of nowhere they're always always a
new one
just creeping up like hope you guys
enjoyed this video leave a like if you
did hit that
bell button if you're new and subscribe
to join
the bro army that's right we're looking
for new recruitments
you have bewitched me buddy and so and i
and love
[Music]